NOT LED TO ANY BREAKTHROUGHS.
THE PATIENCE IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
AT LEAST, SEEMS TO BE WEARING
THIN, WOLF.
>>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH SARA
SIDNER, YOU HAVE IS THE DETAILS
OF THE JURY VERDICT.
>> Reporter: THAT'S RIGHT JUSSIE
SMOLLETT, A JURY HAS FOUND HE IS
GUILTY OF FIVE OF SIX COUNTS OF
DISORDERLY CONDUCT.
NOW, OF THOSE FIVE COUNTS, I'M
GOING TO GIVE YOU A BIT OF WHAT
THE LAW IS THERE, AND WHAT HE
WAS CHARGED WITH, WHAT HE IS NOW
CONVICTED OF.
ON COUNT 1, MAKING A FALSE
POLICE REPORT HE WAS THE VICTIM
OF A HATE CRIME TO OFFICER BAY,
ONE OF THE OFFICERS WHO TOOK
THAT REPORT.
THE SECOND COUNT, A FALSE REPORT
THAT HE WAS A VICTIM OF BATTERY.
THE THIRD COUNSELED THE JURY
FOUND HIM GUILTY OF MAKING A
FALSE REPORT AS THE VICTIM OF A
HATE CRIME TO ANOTHER DETECTIVE,
AND THEN ON COUNT 4, GUILTY OF
MAKING A FALSE POLICE REPORT HE
WAS A VICTIM OF BATTERY TO THAT
SAME DETECTIVE.
COUNT 5, MAKING A FALSE POLICE
REPORT, THIS TIME VICTIM OF A
BATTERY, AGAIN TO THE SAME
POLICE OFFICER.
ON COUNT 6, THAT IS THE ONLY
COUNT THAT THE JURY FOUND HIM
NOT GUILTY.
THAT WAS FOR MAKING A FALSE
POLICE REPORT THAT HE WAS A
VICTIM OF AN AGGRAVATED BATTERY.
SO, WHAT WE NOW KNOW IS THE
JUDGE WILL HAVE TO DECIDE WHAT
HIS SENTENCE IS.
WE SAW JUSSIE SMOLLETT COMING
INTO COURT AS HE HAS EVERY DAY
OF THIS TRIAL, SURROUNDED BY A
LARGE GROUP OF HIS FAMILY AND
SUPPORTERS.
HE IS NOW FOUND GUILTY BY A JURY
OF HIS PEERS HERE IN CHICAGO,
AGAIN, FIVE OF SIX COUNTS HE'S
BEEN FOUND GUILTY ON.
A JUDGE WILL DECIDE WHAT THAT
PUNISHMENT WILL BE, BECAUSE
THERE IS A RANGE HERE, AND THE
JUDGE HAS GREAT DISCRETION TO
DECIDE WHAT HE SHOULD FACE.
THE RANGE IS UP TO THREE YEARS
IN PRISON AND A $25,000 FINE.
THE JUDGE COULD DECIDE ALL
MANNER OF THINGS.
HE COULD DECIDE HE JUST PAYS A
FINE, THAT HE DOESN'T SPEND A
DAY IN JAIL, THIS WILL ALL BY UP
TO THE JUDGE LOOKING AT THE
FACTORS IN THIS CASE, WHETHER
THERE ARE AGGRAVATING FACTORS OR
NOT.
ONE OF THE FACTORS THE JUDGE
WILL CERTAINLY LOOK AT IS ONE OF
THE SUBJECTS THAT THE
PROSECUTORS HAVE BROUGHT UP, BUT
ALSO WHETHER OR NOT HE LIED ON
THE STAND, FOR EXAMPLE, BECAUSE
IN THIS CASE, IT IS ALL ABOUT A
LIE.
IT'S ABOUT A FALSE REPORT TO
POLICE.
IT COULD ALSO BE ABOUT POTENTIAL
AGGRAVATING FACTORS, LYING WHILE
ON THE STAND AS WELL.
THE JUDGE WILL WEIGH ALL OF THAT
AND DECIDE WHAT HIS PUNISHMENT
MAY BE.
AS YOU KNOW, IF YOU HAVEN'T
HEARD OF THIS CASE, IT WOULD BE
A SURPRISE, BECAUSE BACK IN
JANUARY OF 2019, EVERYONE AROUND
THE COUNTRY, EVEN THE WORLD, WAS
TALKING ABOUT THIS ALLEGED HATE
CRIME THAT HE SAID WAS
PERPETRATED ON HIM.
A JURY DECIDED THAT TURNED OUT
TO BE A LIE.
>> THEY CERTAINLY DID, FIVE OF
SIX COUNTS GUILTY AS CHARGED.
STAND BY, I WANT TO BRING IN
LAURA COATES AND JOEY JACKSON
LAURA, LET ME START WITH YOU.
ALSO IT WAS ABOUT THE COUNTS AND
ALSO HOW THE CITY OF CHICAGO
FELT AS THOUGH HE HAD EXPLOITED
THESE VERY, VERY DIFFICULT
TOPICS OF HATE CRIMES,
HOMOPHOBIA, RACISM, TRIED TO
EXPLOIT AND CAPITALIZE, THEY SAY
FOR PUBLICITY AND NOTE RYE YET.
AND WE THINK ABOUT HATE CRIME,
AS YOU KNOW, IT HAD BEEN ON THE
RISE IN THIS COUNTRY FOR THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS.
PART OF THE FRUSTRATION OF THE
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR AND THE
JURISDICTION, PEOPLE ARE LIKELY
TO BE LESS BELIEVED IF THEY ARE
TO REPORT THESE FALSEHOODS, THAT
THERE'S A WAY FOR FUTURE VICTIMS
OF HATE CRIMES, THAT IF YOU
PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION, IF YOU
SAY THESE HOAXES, YOU LESSEN THE
CREDIBILITY OF FUTURE VICTIMS OF
HATE CRIMES.
OF COURSE NOBODY WANTS THAT TO
HAPPEN.
THE JURY HAS SPOKEN CLEARLY ON
THIS ISSUE, THEY WILL NOT
TOLERATE AND THINK IT WAS A
WASTE OF RESOURCE, TAXPAYER
DOLLARS, TO TRY TO ENGAGE IN
THIS BEHAVIOR.
JOEY, HOW SERIOUS IS THIS
CONVICTION ON FIVE COUNTS OF
DISORDERLY CONDUCT?
>> IT'S PROBLEMATIC FOR HIM IN A
NUMBER OF WAYS, THE FIRST OF
WHICH IS, ALTHOUGH SARA
INDICATED, A MAXIMUM OF THREE
YEARS, THE JUDGE CAN GIVE HIM
PROBATION.
AT SHE ALSO INDICATED, WHAT
HAPPENS, WHEN YOU TESTIFY IN A
CASE, THE JUDGE NOW GETS A SENSE
OF WHAT YOU SAID.
WHAT JUSSIE SMOLLETT SET WAS
RESOUNDINGLY REJECTED BY THE
JURY.
THE JURY DID NOT BUY WHAT HE WAS
SELLING.
THAT'S NOT LOST UPON A JUDGE.
YOU CAME INTO THE COURTROOM AND
FABRICATED.
WHY DO I ADD THAT?
I'M SAYING THOUGH THE MAXIMUM IS
THREE YEARS, HE NOW, THE
DEFENDANT MR. SMOLLETT, NOW A
CONVICTED FELON, I DO BELIEVE
HAS EXPOSED HIMSELF TO JAIL
TIME.
I THINK THIS IS A CASE THAT MANY
SAID ABOUT CREDIBILITY.
I WOULD DISAGREE.
TRANSCENDED CREDIBILITY WENT TO
MORE OF WHETHER OR NOT YOUR
FACTS MADE SENSE IN THE EVENT
THAT POLICE HAD FOOTAGE PRIOR TO
THAT PARTICULAR DAY, YOU HAVE TO
EXPLAIN.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO GIVE THE
INDICATION I HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH IT, WHEN YOU'RE SEEN AT
THAT LOCATION.
IT'S KIND OF DIFFICULT WHEN
THERE'S A $3500 CHECK YOU
ALLEGEDLY PAID THESE BROTHERS TO
SAY IT WAS JUST NUTRITION.
IT'S DIFFERENT WHEN POLICE SAY,
SIR, GIVE ME YOUR PHONE, I WANT
TO CHECK IT OUT, AND YOU SAY NO,
I DIDN'T TRUST THE POLICE, I
DIDN'T WANT ANY DNA, SO I STOP
THERE.
THE NARRATIVE HE WAS TELLING IN
TERMS OF THIS HATE CRIME, AND
REALLY FACTUALLY IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE WITH RESPECT TO ALL OF THE
FACTS THAT WENT AGAINST THEM.
WE'RE THANKFUL FOR A JURY SYSTEM
IN THIS COUNTRY THAT CAN REALLY
REACH CONCLUSIONS, AND NOW HE'LL
FACE SENTENCING.
>> NOT ONLY IS HE CONVICTED OF
LYING TO POLICE OFFICERS IN THE
COURSE OF THE INVESTIGATION, BUT
ALSO, YOU KNOW, I'M SURE THE
JUDGE WILL HAVE TO CONSIDER THE
FACT THAT HE WAS, AT LEAST
ACCORDING TO THE JURY, LYING
UNDER OATH DURING THE COURSE OF
THE TRIAL.
>> REMEMBER, HE TOOK THE STAND
IN HIS OWN DEFENSE.
HE WAS PREPARED TO SPEAK,
CONTRARY TO WHAT THE PROSECUTION
WITNESSES SAID, INCLUDING THE
TWO BROTHERS WHO SAID THEY WERE
PAID TO COMMIT THIS HOAX, IN
DEFIANCE OF WHAT WE KNOW TO BE
LOGICAL OF OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
HATE CRIMES, TO HAVE THIS HOAX,
THAT IT WAS A PUBLICITY SCAM.
SO HIM TAKING THE STAND LET TO
HIS EXPOSURE IN THE WAY JOEY HAS
SPOKEN ABOUT.
A JUDGE IS NOW LOOKING AT YOU,
TAKING EVERYTHING YOU HAD TO SAY
AND ASSESSING IT.
HE ALSO IS AN ACTOR.
OUR PAUL CALLEN SPOKE ABOUT IT
LAST WEEK.
THE JURY IS SIZING UP THE PERSON
FOR CREDIBILITY, WONDERING ABOUT
THEIR DEMEANOR, THE
PRESENTATION, THE WAY THEY
DEFEND THEMSELVES.
THEY'RE GOING TO EXPECT A
POLISHED PRESENTATION, WHICH
CUTS AGAINST YOU.
IF THEY BELIEVE YOU ARE
CONSTRUCTING A NARRATIVE IN A
CASE DEFINED BY THE CONSTRUCTION
OF A FALSE NARRATIVE, IT CAN
WEIGH AGAINST YOU.
IT WAS A BIG CALCULATED
STRATEGY, AND NOW WE SO A
MISCALCULATION, OF COURSE, BY
THE DEFENSE TEAM TO CALL HIM TO
THE STAND.
REMEMBER, THEY HAD INITIALLY
DISMISSED THESE CHARGE.
HE HAD FORFELTED A BAIL.
DONE COMMUNITY SERVICE, AND NO,
WE DON'T AGREE INTO THIS NOTION
OF SOMEBODY VERSUS A CASE
DISMISSED.
IT WAS VIEWED AS CELEBRITY
PRIVILEGE GOING ON, GOING AWRY.
HERE,RESPONDED TO
ALL OF THESE FACTORS.
IF THE PROSECUTION IS ABLE TO
MEET THIS BURDEN, AND THEY DID
IN FIVE OUT OF SIX, THE JURY HAS
SPOKEN AND THE JUDGE MUST ABIDE
BY THAT IN HIS OR HER
PRESENTATION OF THE SENTENCE.
>> FIRST OF ALL, WHAT IS THE
MOOD LIKE ON THE GROUND?
DOES THIS VERDICT, GUILTY OF
FIVE OF SIX COUNTS, COME AS A
SURPRISE?
>> Reporter: IT DOES NOT, ONLY
IN THAT, WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT
THE EVIDENCE WAS, THERE WERE
SURVEILLANCE VIDEOS, HUNDREDS OF
HOURS, THOUSANDS OF HOURS OF
VIDEOS THAT POLICE WENT THERE
YOU.
SOME OF THOSE WERE BROUGHT INTO
THE CASE.
THERE WAS TESTIMONY FROM THE TWO
BROTHERS.
THEY CLEARLY KNEW HIM.
THERE WAS CLEARLY A
RELATIONSHIP.
ONE OF THEM WAS HIS TRAINER.
TO HAVE THEM TAKE THE STAND WAS
EXTREMELY SIGNIFICANT, SAYING,
LOOK, WE DID THIS, WE WERE
WRONG.
WE DID THIS, BUT WE WERE TOLD TO
DO THIS.
WE WERE DOING THIS BECAUSE WE
WERE GIVEN $3500, AND WE WERE
TOLD YOU'RE NOT TO HURT HIM THAT
BAD, JUST ROUGH HIM UP A BIT.
THERE WAS ALSO THE VIDEO WITH
THE NOOSE.
THAT VIDEO CAME BACK, I THINK,
IN THE END TO BITE JUSSIE
SMOLLETT.
THE POLICE CAME TO HIM, AND THEY
HAD THEIR BODY CAMS ON.
YOU SEE THE NOOSE AROUND HIS
NECK.
THE PROSECUTION SAYING IT'S VERY
DISHEVELED, BUT WHEN WE FIRST
SAY IT, WHAT HAPPENED, DID YOU
TAKE IT OFF AND PUT IT BACK ON?
HE SAID, WELL, YES, I TOOK IT
OFFER, BUT IT WAS BECAUSE I PUT
IT BACK ON FOR POLICE.
I WAS TOLD BY A COLLEAGUE I
SHOULDN'T HAVE MESSED WITH THE
EVIDENCE, I SHOULDN'T HAVE
TAMPERED WITH IT.
HE SAID THE EXACT OPPOSITE
DURING AN INTERVIEW TO "GMA" HE
TOLD EVERYONE IN THE WORLD HE
INDEED HAD NEVER TAKEN IT OFF.
THERE WERE LOTS OF
INCONSISTENCIES POINTED OUT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S UPSET
FOLKS IN THE CHICAGO AREA ABOUT
THIS IS THE AMOUNT OF TIME AND
MONEY THAT THE POLICE SPENT ON
TRYING TO SOLVE THIS CRIME, THAT
A JURY HAS SAID IS A HOAX, W